hey 42 here 62% of people claim that
their pets understand what they say
whether or not animals can hear
recognize and possibly even understand
what humans say has always been a
profound mystery recent evidence
attempted to reveal once and for all
whether Tony the Terrier knows the
difference between good boy and Tony did
you chew my slippers dogs may respond to
these sentences but do dogs and other
animals actually understand the meaning
behind those sentences or are they just
well-trained you may be very surprised
by what you're about to discover about
animal perception in 1984 researchers at
the National Marine Mammal Foundation in
California noticed something quite
unusual they claims that they heard
voices of people talking around an
enclosure where they kept a beluga whale
known as NOK they were fairly certain it
wasn't anything paranormal
after all the voices sounded so real
eventually a diver went into the tank
when NOK was being held and he noticed a
strangest thing knock the beluga whale
was talking to him in an eerily
human-like voice incredibly the whale
reportedly told the diver to get out
this is an actual recording of Ngoc
imitating human speech
it kind of sounds like a human talking
for a kazoo doesn't it that's because
unlike humans who use their larynx
whales use their nasal tract to produce
sounds making everything sound all
nasally it's believed that not having
lived most of his life in close
proximity to humans learn to mimic the
human voice but the real question is
while snoc merely repeating noises that
he picked up from humans or did he
actually understand the meaning behind
what he was saying
Asian elephants seals and parrots have
also been known to imitate human speech
but do they understand what they are
saying and do they understand what we
say to them in 1891 a German high school
mathematics teacher named Wilhelm von
Osten convinced himself that animals
could be taught basic mathematics he
tried to teach maths to a cat a horse
under bear the cat couldn't care less
and was only interested in itself the
bear was just downright hostile towards
him but the horse showed great promise
after extensive tutelage the horse named
Hans learned to tap his hoof in response
to numbers that von osten would write on
his blackboard if an Austen wrote the
number to Hans would tap his hoof twice
if he wrote for Hans would tap four
times and so on spurred on by this
success von Osten proceeded to teach
Hans to answer basic mathematical
equations varas team would write on the
blackboard two plus two equals and Hans
would tap his hoof four times von Osten
was delighted and exhibited harm to the
public all over germany during these
shows which one often never charge
admission for the crowd were Austrian as
Hans correctly answered an array of
basic maths equations by using his hoof
to tap out the answers Hans could
seemingly add subtract multiply divide
and even work out the square root of a
number
Hans will correct the answer around 89%
of the questions the news of Hans de
genius horse rapidly spread across
Germany but along with Han
fame came critics and skeptics a
psychologist Oscar funks asked to do
some experiment of heartens to which von
Austin agreed
Oscar funks erected a large tents to
perform the experiments to eradicate the
possibility of hardens being influenced
by outside stimuli as a control test
funks asked von osten to step inside the
tent and as Hans mathematical questions
like he usually does as expected
Hans got most of the questions correct
however Foggs then asked von Osten to
move a little farther away from Hans
whilst he asked two questions and
subsequently Hans got far fewer answers
correct
finally funks told von Osten to ask hard
questions that he knew von Osten did not
know the answer to when von osten asked
these questions the accuracy of Hondas
answers fell to almost zero it appeared
that in order for Hans to get the answer
correct the person asking the question
had to know the answer to the question
also these results were very strange but
incredibly interesting so funks
investigated further
he observed von Austin's facial
expressions and posture whilst he was
asking cons to questions funks to
noticed von Austin's facial expression
and posture changed right after he asked
a question his face and posture would
tense up an expectation of Hans is
answer however each time Hans tapped his
hoof and got closer to the correct
answer von Austin's posture and
expressions would relax and become
happier because he was relieved that
Hans had seemingly arrived at the
correct answer all by himself
it transpired that the horse was
receiving small visual clues that acted
as feedback the horse would start
tapping as soon as he observed von Osten
asking the question and then ten single
when the tension had alleviated from von
Austin's face Hans would stop tapping
his hoof Hans was never actually doing
any mathematics he was simply well
attuned to his owners visual clues von
Osten was shocked at this revelation he
he was completely unaware that he was
providing cons with these unconscious
visual clues he genuinely thought that
his horse was a genius the results of
funked experiment had enormous effects
on how all scientific experiments would
be carried out in the future this
phenomenon came to be known as the
clever Hans effect the clever Hans
effect as we know it today is when an
experimenter unwittingly alters the
results of an experiment simply because
he or she is expecting a certain result
the simple expectation for something to
happen can have huge consequences on an
experiment results without the
experimenter even realizing it these
days necessary measures are taken when
working with both humans and animals to
prevent the clever Hans effect from
altering the results of experiments a
border collie named Rico came into the
spotlight in 2004 after being
intensively studied by animal
psychologists from the Max Planck
Institute for evolutionary anthropology
in Germany the researchers showed such a
great interest in Rico because his
owners reported that he could understand
over 200 words a feat previously unheard
of in the canine kingdom to test whether
eco skills were a bunch of fluff or a
truly bona fide talent the researchers
set up an experiment the researchers
arranged 200 toys on the floor in a room
adjacent to where Rica was being held
they did this ten toys at a time each
toy had a unique name such as for fee or
squeezy
Rico's owners had already trained him to
remember the name of each toy each time
the researchers would let Rico into the
room with the toys and asked Rico to
fetch a toy then another toy and then
another until Rico had fetched all 10
toys whilst the researchers were issuing
commands to Rico they stayed on the
other side of a dividing wall where Rico
could hear them but not see them to
eliminate the clever Hans effect in
total Rico successfully remembered and
retrieved 93% of the toys impressive but
this was only a test of Rico's memory
not his cognitive for
action ie his ability to use logic and
inference just like a human so the
researchers did a second experiment they
arranged seven items in the room with an
eighth item which was brand new which
they gave a unique name to Rico had
never seen or heard the name of this new
item before amazingly when Rico is
lesson to the room and us to fetch the
new item he was fairly quickly able to
infer which was the new toy and fetched
it straight away
Rico seemingly used a process of
deduction and elimination this is called
fast mapping a process where one is able
to quickly learn a new concept after a
single exposure to brand new information
human toddlers do this all the time it's
how they learn even more amazingly Rico
is able to fetch the new toys again four
weeks later having only seen them once
out of the six new items that Rico is
shown four weeks prior
he remembered free of them four weeks
later interestingly three out of six is
the same rate at which adult humans are
able to remember things that they saw
four weeks ago chaser
is another border collie who can
reportedly remember the name of a
thousand toys and can retrieve each one
of them just like Rico but chaser has
another unique talent she is able to
recognize verbs from a young age chasers
owner a retired psychologist trained
chaser to understand and utilize free
verbs nose pour and fetch when chasers
owner says poor slinky chaser will go
over to the toy named slinky and put her
pour on it similarly if nose slinky is
said chaser will put her nose on the
slinky toy and when fetched slinky is
said chaser will fetch the slinky toy
chasers owner is able to swap the verb
and the name of the toy for any one of a
thousand different toys and chaser will
go over to the correct toy and do the
correct action almost 100% of the time
that's about the same cognitive ability
as a free year-old human child this also
demonstrates something of stone
King chaser doesn't simply remember each
and every command it's not just a
cheaper memory trick Chase's brain is
actually using cognitive function to
determine what to do in each given
situation this is no different to how a
human brain works although this is
rather basic stuff for an adult human
it's an amazing display of cognitive
ability and logical inference for an
animal it demonstrates that dogs do
understand what we say provided they are
given the opportunity to learn these
human-like concepts as a puppy but
that's no different from a human humans
have to learn this stuff too we aren't
born knowing whoa go get daddy a beer
means as a baby we learn the individual
words that construct that sentence and
then as a toddler we use our brains
cognitive ability especially our fast
mapping ability to know what we should
do when those words are arranged into
that sentence in that order
just like Rico and chaser are doing dogs
aren't able to learn as fast or to the
same extent as humans so realistically
their ability is capped when compared to
humans however provided they are given
the correct education and training from
an early age dogs most definitely can
understand at least a small percentage
of what you say to them so when you say
time for walkies and your dog goes
freakin mental it may not just be
because they have associated the word
walkies with running about outside with
their beloved owner there's actually
some very basic level of understanding
there but don't think you can go and
have full-blown nice enteric
conversations with your canine body they
may understand the odd word or two but
first and foremost dogs use smell to
communicate and differentiate between
objects and people they're probably
going to understand a lot more of what
you're trying to communicate to them if
you roll around in the garden for 10
minutes then let them sniff you then if
you try to explain to them why you've
had such a bad day at the office
so far we've only talked about dogs
horses and whales but what about over
animals after all a spectrum of animal
cognition spans the entire animal
kingdom take koko the gorilla for
example Koko is a female gorilla who has
learnt a modified version
of American sign language Coco was
taught from a very early age and now she
can reportedly understand and use 1,000
different signs of what her trainer
calls gorilla sign language and she
understands over 2,000 words of spoken
English naturally Coco has been the
subject of numerous scientific studies
articles and books but whether or not
Coco actually understand sign language
in the same way a human does is a topic
of hot debate some researchers argue
that Coco hasn't actually mastered sign
language at all and she doesn't
understand the words she is signing they
insist that Coco human-like sign
language abilities are simply a result
of operant conditioning operant
conditioning is when someone loves to do
something because there's a reward at
the end of it for example if he showed a
toddler three different colored boxes
blue green and red
and then placed a sweet in the green box
the toddler would then learn to always
open the green box in the future in
order to get the sweet Coco may have
simply learned to make certain shapes
and signs with her hands because she is
rewarded for doing so video evidence
showed that Coco was also being
influenced by the clever Hans effect her
trainers were giving her unconscious
facial clues to prompt her to make
certain gestures with her hands despite
all this Coco's trainers are adamant
that there's more going on in Coco's
head than researchers give her credit
for one piece of evidence which suggests
a greater level of cognition and Coco's
brain occurred when Coco's baby was
taken away from her the day after her
baby was removed she reportedly signed
the word baby to her keeper this is
known as displacement the ability to
talk about objects that are not
currently present in the room and is
something that we thought was unique to
humans and it's very rarely observed in
the animal kingdom also Coco has been
known to talk about new objects that she
hasn't even been taught how to sign for
example Coco has never been taught the
sign language for the word rink but Coco
combines the signs for finger
bracelet to refer to a ring and if you
think about it a ring is just a tiny
bracelet for your finger that's pretty
smart going KOCO events such as this
suggests that KOCO has a higher level of
understanding of the word she is
actually signing but there's a dark side
to all that gorilla intelligence KOCO
enjoys seeing human nipples and she
often asks her female caregivers using
sign language to show her their nipples
this unusual behavior actually resulted
in a sexual harassment lawsuit by one of
Coco's female caregivers in 2005 maybe
it's not such a good idea we try to
communicate with animals after all
dolphins are often said to be one of the
smartest animals in the world and they
certainly proved it in a 1984 study two
bottlenose dolphins were taught human
language the first dolphin named Phoenix
was taught how to comprehend human
speech the second dolphin akika my was
taught a form of sign language both
dolphins were taught a large variety of
words such as object names actions and
object modifiers all of which could be
combined and rearranged into hundreds of
unique sentences to form a command for
example swim to the blue ring or pick up
the red ring the commands were given to
the dolphins using computer-generated
voices and videos to prevent the clever
Hans effect both dolphins were able to
comprehend and execute the given
commands at a much higher success rate
than what would be considered chance
understanding words and simple one-word
commands is one thing but for an animal
to understand complex free - five word
commands and accurately follow them is
quite simply astonishing experiments
such as these prove that many animals
have an unprecedented level of
understanding of human speech and
communication up to now we've only
explored a Maya fraction of intellect
within the animal kingdom who knows what
some animals are really capable of a
real-life Planet of the Apes may be just
around the
but until then you should probably watch
what you're saying around your pets they
may be listening a bit more attentively
than you think thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42
you